[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning did
you hear the one about the self-driving
car that got lost
well some folks in a san francisco
neighborhood can tell you all about it
last month waymo a sister company of
google began testing its self-driving
vehicles in san francisco and neighbors
on one dead end street realized they
were seeing a lot of these cars for no
apparent reason
wilson walker from our san francisco
station k-picks has the story
and i noticed it while i was sleeping i
awoke to a strange home that i thought
there was a spacecraft outside my
bedroom window
the visitors jennifer king is talking
about don't just come at night
they come all day right to the end of
this dead-end street by the presidio
where there is nothing else to do but
make some kind of a multi-point turn and
head out the way they came in now not
long after that car is gone there will
be another which will make the same turn
and leave before another car shows up
and does the exact same thing and while
there are some pauses it never really
stops there are some days where
it can be up to 50 i mean it's literally
every five minutes and you know i'm
we're all working from home
uh and so we this is what we hear yeah
this is what we hear at several points
on this day they showed up on top of
each other these automated cars but
equipped with human drivers in case of
emergency stopping in a queue as if
completely baffled by a dead end
don't really have a preference either
way but it is a little bit odd that
they're over here so much
and especially across a slow street into
a one one block street it's a little bit
peculiar have you ever seen them pick
anyone up or drop anyone off no
they're just i think doing their testing
so it's definitely they're exploring
something on this little piece of land
on 15th
the frequency of the visits is sparking
conversation in the neighborhood but for
now neighbors can only guess as to what
exactly is causing this
we have talked to the drivers who don't
have much to say other than i think it's
just programmed and they're just doing
their job in an emailed statement a
waymo spokesperson says that the cars
quote have to take a u-turn due to the
presence of slow street signage so the
waymo driver was obeying the same road
rules that any car is required to follow
unquote waymo added that they are happy
that the neighbors called this issue to
their attention for cbs saturday morning
i'm wilson walker in san francisco
there it is i was in san francisco last
week
and i saw those cars i said there's no
driver did you think it was a spaceship
no i didn't my handy-dandy producer
chris weiker explained the whole thing
to me so chris weiker's the best she's
the best she knows it all